okay
hmm
um
afternoon councillors ladies and
gentlemen welcome along to our
uh june meeting of council can i just
ask you
remain standing for the opening prayer
please
father we just come before you again
thank you for the privilege that you've
given us to deliberate on
matters of importance for this community
and as we go through the agenda today
i ask that you'll give us the wisdom and
guidance that we need in the name of
jesus christ amen
thank you
okay welcome
councillors we don't have any apologies
do we have any declaration of counsellor
interests with regarding
this particular agenda we're dealing
with today
there is none thank you
right then we'll move on to confirmation
of minutes
and and reports and we have
confirmation of the minutes the ordinary
meeting of council
held on tuesday 11 may uh
full receipt and adoption would somebody
like to move they'd be seen as a true
and correct record
of that meeting move councillor dixon
double second of that councillor
phillips thank you
is there any alteration required of the
report
it is not i'll put that motion all those
in favor please say aye
against the motion of this carrick thank
you item four urgent
late business now you will have noticed
in your uh hubs that there's a
an item that has just arrived there with
regard to
streets alive and it is in response to
a letter i wrote to the um the ceo of
waka katahi
and and subsequently her reply to that
which i believe
requires council to give some direction
uh with regard to the future of of
streets alive
so my intention is to discuss this my
atom
this item at the conclusion of this
meeting and the last item on this
meeting will somebody i'll move that way
would somebody like to second that
councillor reed thank you all those in
favor please say aye
against thank you it's carried
right we're on to item five which is
a southland regional spaces and places
strategy and we have a summary here from
from sport southland with a
recommendation
included that we partake in this
particular
strategy certainly looks like a good way
to go
but um mr chief executive do you want to
make any comment
before i open it up for discussion
uh just to say your worship that
yes uh it's been an initiative that's
been supported by
the three um councils in southland uh
tomorrow at the deliberative meeting you
will be invited to make
a decision on whether to contribute ten
thousand dollars
uh to that strategy uh to assist in the
employment of a staff member by sport
southland
but today you all you're being invited
to do is to
endorse the strategy itself okay
so thank you open for discussion any
discussion
or moving a recommendation
okay thank you councillor reed so you're
moving the entire recommendation on page
18.
thank you is there a segment for that
councilor macphail thank you
no further discussion i'll put the
motion all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors
so move on to the civic financial
services
annual report you have a copy of your
annual
theory annual report included in the
agenda
uh with the recommendation from the
chief financial officer that it be
received do you want to make any comment
to this your name uh three years ship i
think the
um the report should just be taken as
read it's for information only
okay so that's open for discussion and
or receipt
thank you councillor heisted to have a
segment of that council bulger
is there any discussion does not i'll
put the motion all those in favor please
say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors
um gorgeous residence
survey and the results that we have um
before you unfortunately the
communication marketing manager is not
with us today
so um do you want to make any comment
to this mr chief executive
not specifically worship i think
we all know that the survey occurred
at a time when streets alive was being
rolled out and may the results may
reflect that and so probably it's
one of those surveys that we will
historically look back and say well
there may be some qualifications to the
results because there was
a a rather new and some would say
controversial program been trotted out
by the council at that same time
okay um open for
comment or question or suggestions
counselor reed
yeah um it certainly would be good to
get a little bit more information
uh from some of the surveyed
uh personnel to get a sense of what they
are
what they're actually suggesting uh
and i think probably the communications
manager talks a little bit about that
in her summary you know potentially for
next year
trying to dig down a little bit more
with some of the questions
and the recipients counselor heist said
yeah thank you always have a question
around future
engagement in terms of reaching out with
the
landlines being phased out it's
approximately 50 was it all a little bit
less than the total feedback came
through
telephone no 380 people 242
by online without telephones
is it just going to be an online
platform or is that a secret
um okay i think there was a good point
councillor i said one that i had in my
mind too
and i think that probably deserves a
separate discussion with the
communication
manager when she is available to talk to
council about what the options are for
getting
a wider spectrum of of feedback
certainly it is challenging with the
various platforms that we have
and there's you know notably there's a
reduction in landlines available
for people so that does can't cut down
the options for
um for quite a few i guess we're not the
only ones facing this so
there will be a number of organizations
both business and um
and government organizations working
hard on how do we get the feeling of our
of our stakeholders so
we need to make some effort there
council read sorry um
thank you your worship um because of
that very fact
um maybe we need to be looking at taking
the questions to the people as
i mean having a a caravan out
and asking people individually at the
supermarkets or in their streets
because i noticed that it's
it's sort of like a 50 50 call for
online and
written surveys but it's interesting
also
to note that the online results
from those particular ratepayers seem to
have a negative trend
um and just yeah but anyway i'd be quite
keen to see us as a council
take those surveys out to our rate
payers
as opposed to expecting them to come in
or do it online
um yeah so we do need to
um spend a little bit time contemplating
what uh
what the plan going forward is um
so is there any particular section of
the survey that councils would like to
comment on
or council dixon through your worship i
was
a little bit concerned i see that the
community
want more done with our waste it seems
to be
one of the highlights of the survey and
i i'm pleased that we've got a committee
that's
dealing with that but wondering how the
community
community could have an input into that
as well because
some i know i've spoken to some people
who have some very good ideas about
dealing with their waste so my
understanding is that that working party
will be
um recommending some um stakeholder
involvement in that council mcphail do
you want to make a comment yes
early worship just in regard to that um
the working group's working on terms of
reference
in relation to what that component will
make up
and it has been agreed amongst that
group clearly there's um
a number of people in the community that
would be able to provide us with some
excellent or even alternate suggestions
around
our waste management so that clearly
will help with that
we're hoping yeah look i i
i think it's absolutely imperative that
we do have
uh residents involved in that discussion
um
and like it's fairly clear that while we
thought we made the right decisions for
the right reasons
that the message hasn't got across as to
why we're doing some
some things that we're doing and some of
the approaches that we're taking
um so we need to need to work
a lot closer with community to work out
what the way forward is
um your worship i just have another
question
how do we address the community that
are not satisfied with our leadership
and i think
how could we get accountability out to
them for our decisions
because i feel that they feel we're
making decisions but
um they don't understand why we've made
those decisions
yeah i guess and if you look at the
trend
and if you look at the trends and a
number of councils they'll be similar
i would think similar here we're a
little bit down this year
um if i had an answer for that
i think i would proffer profit now um i
guess the only
the only definitive way to
understand whether people have
confidence in you or the
council collectively is is that at
election time and while we're doing this
survey
every three years you're only ever going
to get a certain
amount of feedback whereas ultimately
everybody has a chance to
choose who they'd like to be involved in
the council going forward
on a three yearly basis now that may not
be
the way that everybody wants to see it
done and people would like to be a
little bit more involved
on an ongoing basis but it is incredibly
hard
to be able to engage with everybody uh
all the time
um but that's not to say we shouldn't
try to do better
councillor phillips and i think council
bulger was going to say something with
you
uh you thank you um yeah i see the
material residents feel less positive
about the district and it's probably a
question that we could probably ask next
uh wednesday night at the town meeting
so
yep yeah we might to be interesting to
get a feedback on that one
so i think that's a good point uh
council phillips i think councillors
have probably had an invitation to that
meeting in matera
next wednesday night which is a
particularly good initiative i think of
the community board so
hopefully we'll see a few councillors
faces um in
in the room that night counselor bulger
did you ever say no
no
good okay
is there anything further on the survey
um
but bearing in mind that we want to meet
with the communications manager
particularly to
to talk about what the future of the
survey is
in the not too distant future would
somebody like to move the receipt
of that report thank you council
guardian
second to counselor bulger thank you all
those in favor please say hi
against the motion is carried thank you
brings us on to item eight which is a
memo from the admin manager
with regard to a new staff members
warrant do you want to make any comment
here susan
it's pretty straightforward any
questions or comments from councillors
about this
thank you okay do i have a second for
that
council bulger thank you is there any
discussion
does not i'll put the motion all those
in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
uh right we're on to item nine um
and more multi-sports complex
change in user fees and charges
and we have a memo here from
the aquatic services manager martin
knackerath i don't think
martin's here today i think it's
reasonably straightforward but
luna do you want to make any comment on
the financial side of things here
thank you your worship um i think the
key point to
the aquatic services manager's report is
that fees have not gone up for the last
three or four years
and when you compare it to other
facilities of it of a similar type
around the country
we are a lot more i guess
user friendly and payer friendly than in
other areas
so whilst whilst we appreciate the
community is still
um recovering from covert it
you know we we have to have increasing
costs to cover and
this is this is the way we cover it when
you look at the charges overall compared
to our
and neighbours we're still within kiwi
of them and below some of them
and it's not as if the the maori sport
is self-sustaining by
entry fees by any mandarins
okay um look open for discussion any
councillors
councillor heisted
you thank you just in terms of your
neighbours do we have any idea
about the cargo um splash palace i know
it's probably not
a similar facility but it'll be good to
understand
do we have that anyway hmm it's not on
that list is uh
if you just give the chief executive a
minute he'll find that for you
so just if we come back to invercargill
and then a couple of six
other questions or comments council reed
thank you your worship um given the fact
that minimum wage increases have
occurred
um quite steeply recently and also the
cost of chemicals
i don't see any problem with raising the
fee
the only thing i would is 50 cents over
three years okay or it's over that same
years if it was a 20
cent increase it would be a 60 cent
increase
so just for your information counselor i
said 650 for an adult
and in the cargo sorry
councillor that's fine i'm quite happy
to move it
um given that the increased costs that
we're facing through wage increase and
chemical costs
just two of the things thank you i think
council dixon wants to make a comment as
well do you
want to speak before we take the motion
worship um i'm just
i'd like just to say that the senior
citizens i mean i think we
need to be
advantaging them a little bit because
over 60s it's good to have them being
active but
i guess 50 cents is not too much and the
other question i have is about a
preschool caregiver free what
that actually means because i understand
there's a lot of children that are just
dropped off there that
that haven't got um caregivers or
parents
preschool
three three worship this was this
preschool so the rules are that
preschool
they must be uh attended by an adult
uh at all times so children might be lit
might be
dropped off but they would be over eight
years of age at least
i think it's anybody underage got to
have an adult with them
is that what caregiver free means that
they must have an error yes
i assume so right thank you
okay um so you're prepared to move those
items council read thank you do i have a
seconder for that
councilman thank you any further
discussion
does not i'll put the motion all those
in favor please say aye
gays the motion is carried right that
brings us on to
um proposed fees and charges generally
for
the council operation uh for the year
uh commencing one july and we have a
report from the chief financial officer
uh lorna do you wanna talk us through
this one please
thank you euryship on the whole we are
proposing to keep a majority of our fees
the same and stable this year we know
the community is
facing a rates increase so we wanted to
keep things as stable as possible but
there are a couple of areas that have
not been addressed for a couple
for a wee while and we wanted to do that
um
the symmetries fees and charges will be
a separate report later on
this evening um the the libraries one of
the things we are
proposing for the library is to actually
reduce some of our fees
and take away the charges on adult
fiction
in water we have we've used the barrel
index to
increase a couple of small charges there
you'll notice that they are in
highlighted and yellow
again this is just to keep in line with
inflation and again these haven't been
increased for
two or three years um the staff costs
uh that are charged out these have been
increased since we introduced them back
in oh gosh 2015 2016 so
you can imagine in five or six years
salary costs and costs associated with
that have increased animal management we
we introduced new fees last year in a
new
charging scheme so we want to keep those
the same to let them get in and and see
how they how they're tracking
um building control fees were subject to
previous meetings i think and the rest
of them are
fairly much staying the same happy to
have
some questions okay um
the item is open for discussion although
mr executive do you want to make any
comment before we open it up no so it's
open for discussion council
grant thank you your worship
just querying all other departments are
trying to
to do user pays such as um
the building department's just done that
the uh swimming pool
just we've just agreed to that now the
library is wanting to drop their fees
it doesn't sit well with me to be honest
i might be
slightly conflicted for the simple fact
that i've got a book shot
yeah look i think i i i'm i'll let you
to
have the discussion but i think you need
to flag that you do have a conflict i do
have a slight conflict because yeah i do
sell the odd book
in magazines and what magazines as well
but
yeah i mean i should actually butt out
of this conversation but to me
it just doesn't make sense thanks
okay so castle reed thank you your
worship
um i can understand the reasoning behind
it and i think anything that
um encourages people to go read take
books home
is an absolute positive and i'm quite
happy to see those
charges dropped counselor
heisted thanks you russia
i'm a little bit different the
councillor reid i think we need to look
at the library as
a package we're going through a
redevelopment at the moment on proposal
development library
there's been discussions around how the
books are
dished out whether that's through people
or through machinery
and also how that whole resourcing is
going to work so i prefer that we look
at the library
in its entirety how it's going to
operate once it's redeveloped
what the costs are the overall structure
rather than just striking the fees out
today
i think it's a bit early and would it i
suppose the question achieves x
would it be appropriate to get a report
someone down the track to look at the
library
as an opera in an operational sense
what's in its new premises
uh can certainly do that uh through uh
your worship
um this this is really absolute
political
decision here um you can you're entitled
to
uh leave the fees as they are increase
the fees or drop the fees
and ideas say that what we're witnessing
around the table reflects probably that
the divergence of uh community opinion
on this very subject
in terms of a report on the library and
how it all come together
we can certainly do that and i take it
council heisted
you're thinking that the fees structure
may want to be reviewed
to reflect a wider range and higher
standard of service being received
as a result of the new facility that's
correct
council bulger and then councillor gavin
um
yeah i think there's a couple of issues
here
libraries in receipt of substantial
support through rates so it's not fully
funded from
fees from books so i suggest that the
alteration and fees is to encourage more
usage of
a particular section of books and i
think that's
what um counselor reid explained so
look i i don't have a problem with this
by all means it'll be good to have
a report on the workings of the library
and it'd be happy to receive that but
for tonight's uh purpose of the the
topic tonight i'm happy to move the
recommendation
okay before we and and the and the fee
adjustment as it's recommended
okay so you you're moving that now okay
right before i asked council garden to
speak is there a seconder for that
council reid thank you council garden
just wanting us a bit more information
on actually how much dropping that
charge drops out of the system
that's really what we need to know just
mentioned in there
2000 was it just be at the top
two to four percent of the total costs
yeah yeah so we need to know what the
dollar terms are right
okay right oh so any
further comment on this particular one
um if there's not we have a motion
that the motion that the recommendation
be
adopted always in favorably say aye
against right so show of hands please
um those in favor
right the motion is lost so we're back
to square one
uh would somebody like to
propose an alternate please
decide i'd move the recommendation with
the exception of
the change in library charges that they
be left as they are
in 2021 into 2022.
and do you want to add to that that a um
a report be commissioned when it's
appropriate
on the operation of the library in its
new revised form yeah okay i'll second
that
right right so everybody's clear on the
on the motion right all those favor
please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
right we move on then to
health and safety report
and we have a report from the human
resources manager
and do you want to make any comment
susan
um
right any questions uh or comments from
councillors uh with regard to health and
safety in
the council if there's not would
somebody like to move that be received
do a comment um abusive customers
that's probably a statement rather than
a comment or a quick i just think it's
really disappointing
that actually people come on here
the staff that are that are
paid to give service and i know from the
chief executive they're expected to give
service to the best of the ability
and that the standard of service is is
the target is very high
so it does disappoint me that that's not
appreciated
and i guess the the fact that i'd like
people to understand who who might be
hear what i've got to say is the staff
have no ability to defend themselves
so i think to come in here and abuse the
staff
particularly cowardly
that's all i've got to say look i'll
just take you up on that point on
and i agree and and i think it is
becoming
reasonably widespread throughout local
government and new zealand and that
doesn't make it
acceptable and by any manner of means
but just notice today i think it was
where
um waitaki district council all their
front-facing staff inside and outside
will be having cameras attached to them
now
just because of the abuse that they're
having to pick up so
no that's it's a problem with society
and it's not acceptable
but hopefully we don't have to get to
the point where everybody has to have a
camera
uh right so with a
motion from council bulger that will be
received i've signed up for that
counselor garden thank you all those in
favor please say aye
against the motion is carried right we
have a
report here from the chief executive
with regard to
three waters reform and an update
after a number of meetings and it seems
to be a
a fast moving topic this one although we
don't have any
real clarity about what the the end
result is going to be but hopefully that
won't be
too far away i get it's a reasonably
um
self-explanatory um document but do you
want to make any comment
steve uh just to say your worship look
uh the this reform
is uh really starting to get gained
ahead of steam
and as i promised at the start of the
year it will
feature regularly on council agendas
the more information we get the more
i guess yearning we have for the detail
and the government to
disclose its hand about what the reform
will look like
if trotted out but the reports that we
are
generating around
the options open to councils all point
to the obvious question obvious issue
that is
the acute funding challenge
to councils in relation to upgrading
their
three waters assets to both replace aged
assets and to comply with
upgraded regulatory requirements
uh it's fair to say the the big uh
crunchy issues will come
before the council in the latter half of
this calendar year where by december the
council is expected to make a decision
as to whether to opt-in
or opt out and
it would seem that this juncture that
the report that you would get from
myself on that will most likely probably
be an invitation to opt-in
uh just given the stark risks involved
in staying outside and
being exposed to uh
forces that really are beyond your
control and one of the things i do find
a little disconcerting about these
reforms is the type of qualified staff
that are acquired
by these new entities and where those
staff may come from
not just from a school district council
point of view but from
a new zealand incorporated point of view
because i have some grave doubts as to
where there's enough
for example engineers to actually grace
the seats that are available in both the
rig the water regulator
and the new entities to be created and
they will be
hungry for resources um
and i do say there will be a real
competition on for them
and so therefore things like transition
to any new regime will be very important
so that
the councils who are asked to carry on
have the staff that can carry on and to
deliver
a service in those intervening years
before it's transferred to
at this stage and unknown entity
thank you steve and i guess the the more
i learn about
uh the challenge ahead of us the more
gargantuan that challenges
and the more i really worry about our
ability
as a district um to to deal with that by
ourselves and
in fact i get to the point where i don't
think we can and
and i think that probably um
there's a sort of a realization across
the nation
particularly from local government
particularly the smaller units of local
government
that the opt out provision
is one that really doesn't make sense
because
for the reform to work it really relies
on all units including auckland
to be part of this to to make it work
the idea of this particular council
committing
to spend about 330 million dollars over
the next 30 years to deal with the water
and waste problems
and challenges that we have here is
ridiculous
we we our community couldn't afford to
do that in my mind
so it's an interesting space to be in
and probably
one of the more or the fast developing
discussions that are going on nationwide
as well is what is the future of local
government so
if water both the waste and fresh water
and storm waters are taken out of the
scene
and takes their ability as a council to
have a really robust engineering
department
what does that mean for us as a council
and what is the role
of councils per se into the future and i
think there is
some real opportunities there and some
quite exciting ones but it's probably
not what we've been used to
in the past and i think it's a space to
watch
very very carefully but the report is
open
for discussion and any comment that
councillors would like to make
council garden yeah just um was
interesting there was not a lot
covering rural water schemes and they
probably come into that 75 000 schemes
which is an awful lot of water schemes
and um a lot of them are privatised
and just in their own backyard we've got
a tamar wanting to go
out on their own and they met with the
regulator
uh and the health people last month
and it was quite interesting the
regulator virtually said well if you go
on your own
you're going to um you know have to
abide by the rules which is fair enough
and then
get um qualified company to run it
uh but then it's interesting the fact
was that you know if if it doesn't
go to go as planned you'll just be
absorbed into the company
and um which is probably a fair enough
thing but if they do make a go of it
which is going to be a lot of them out
there
they're going to have to somehow bring
them all in and
it's quite a hard gonna be very hard for
the
for the short term anyway but um
it says i think it's going to be a wee
bit harder for them to put raw water
schemes into the
into the box because if they put their
unit charges up to what a household
charge in the raw water schemes a lot of
farmers will go off those schemes and
make those schemes totally uneconomic
and um so it's going to be
an interesting space to watch but
whether we wanted
a timer has to ever go i think it would
be a good idea and if they want to
if they do do it right and some of these
schemes
have to form have company and people
employed to do their
uh work and if it doesn't work for them
it could be absorbed into the company
so i think you're talking absolute sense
here
um and the more i understand about the
75 000 schemes um and probably
75 percent of the water they deliver is
for animals
as opposed to probably even higher than
that as opposed to humans
the option to treat the water for the
human population
at the household is really the only way
to do it
um do you want to
yeah okay so any further comment
counselor hosted
you thanks for russia for me page 208 of
the
presentation or 210 on our ipads really
says it all
you know any perception that that we're
selling the family silver here
is clearly overcome to see that you know
2450 could be the highest
water charge in addition to your rates
but now i guess score will be
towards the upper end of that if it was
on its own um
whereas it could be as low as 725 by by
joining i know that's been covered but
just be great if this community could
understand the challenges that
we face on our own yep
goodness through you you worship
i saw some discussion about government
discussing whether
um they were going to make it mandatory
for every council to be involved and
not having that opt out option is that
on the cards
that they could have i think as time
goes on
and the more we hear about the scale of
the challenge um
i don't think and there's a lot of
people up and down the country don't
think it'll work unless everybody's in
so um watch this space
but i would imagine that the opt out
option will be
probably removed at some point but i'm
guessing as much as anybody else's
okay okay
is there any other comment from
councillors if there's not would
somebody like to move the receipt of the
report please
council davis thank you double secondary
councillor reed thank you
all those in favor please say hi okay
emotions carried and look thank you
councillors for those that
took the time to spend the large part of
the day
at the presentation a couple of weeks
ago i think it was well worth while
hearing that okay we'll move on then to
stop bank work program progress report
and
do you want us to make any comment on
this
steve
not really your worship i think it's
it's it's actually uh
reasonably dated that report um i'm not
sure whether
mr bayless has got any comments to make
speak up
okay council got on
just on the uh transfer station is is
the issue being
made clear there whether it just needs
the stock bank raised going into the
transfer station stop that wiki river
coming in or
what's what's
so what discussions were held at the
time when the
transfer station were developed but it
seems like it is on court district
council to extend their uh
those defenses through the transfer
station
so the councilor um
dixon and then council might fail
through your worship i just wondering is
that was that the issue with ontario
street
was at the um transfer station
well that's apparently that's what
um some people have a feeling it was the
problem
yeah councilman farm
just done further to what um councillor
gathering has said
probably a query through the ceo in
regard to that issue
with the transfer station have we got
um facility should that river do the
same thing it did last february where it
did come out that
we previously discussed that lane access
which was to the um
south of the transfer station which
caused some of that flooding
and if we haven't done the actual uh
remedial work
do we have access because i know
contractors indicated they could have
placed um
concrete blocks or similar to stop some
of that flooding coming out onto
toronto street i think it was
have we advanced that at all
so if i can step in and for your worship
um those discussions
discussions about the long-term fix are
being had
but in the meantime those faults both
selfish street and every transfer
station
are very well known to us so we would
put defenses in there temporarily if we
got hit by another similar sort of flood
tomorrow
so the status of the working party we've
got councillors on that working party
have we is it just is it a working party
of offices
um discussions we've had today just
being through staff
and environment southland okay
so i thought we had did we have a
wedding
your worship i think uh i think
previously
at the last uh previous council did your
previous council had uh
councillor graham sharp
yeah so i think given uh the interest in
this subject
and you know some of the um
weather events that we are having i
think it's important that councillors
stay
connected to this particular issue
uh and i'm wondering uh steve if you
could bring a recommendation
to council in the near future about
how councillors can be connected to the
stop bank work program on a regular
basis so we
um so we don't lose touch with that
okay um council got on
yeah just another thing i noted to the
environment southland about it was um
the lack of
warning on the waikeka river there's
only one measuring station at hamilton
park and i think there used to be one at
willowbank it's been taken out and we
don't the only other measuring station
is
uh rain gauge and wind valley okay and
most farmers you know don't know what's
going to come into it that's
them and same with the town the town
doesn't get any time whereas if you had
a measuring station
up the river at least a willow bank
you've got two or three hours
to put some stuff in place if it's at
hamilton street you've got
no no time so i think that's that's
obviously something that um elected
member input would be
valuable on so you need to make note of
that
okay is there any other comment with
regard to the
the flood bank working party does not
will somebody like to move that it be
received
councillor bulger double seconder for
that
councillor mctinnell thank you all those
in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried right
councils will be aware as i notified at
the beginning of the meeting there is
an item of urgent late business that i
would like to
bring before council now
for discussion it relates to the streets
live
and we have a memo from the chief
executive which
hopefully you've all got it's um it's
very
very recent and i'm just gonna
give everybody a few minutes to locate
that on your device
and to have a read through uh before we
discuss it
oh yeah yeah there is so there is
another item on there as well that's
right
so it's two items uh cemeteries fees and
charges and
streets alive
okay has everybody located it and had a
quick read
need any more time
if not um we'll begin with uh cemeteries
fees and charges and we have a memo here
from the chief
financial officer um
do you want to just make some comment on
this particular item
thank you your ship and through your
worship um cemeteries and fees uh
a topic that we have discussed at
various workshops leading through
leading up to the ltp adoption
um in particular uh the last time we
reviewed
uh symmetry fees and charges three years
ago and starting effective from the
first of july 2018.
when you compare the feasing charges we
currently have
to what our neighbouring councils have
we are significantly below
what other councils are charging and
even with the proposed 10 increase will
still on the whole be below what
neighbours are charging for
the service um my understanding is we
provide a very
not having experienced it myself we do
provide a very good service
um to our community um and you know they
they're an amazing they're amazing um
asset
as well okay
so um this particular item is open for
discussion and or question
and or recommendation
is there any questions you would like to
ask of lornae at this point
steve do you want to make any comment no
i think it's reasonably straightforward
so um councillor um
phillips is moving the recommendation of
a second after that councilman mctinnell
thank you
any discussion from councillors does not
i'll put the motion all those in favor
please say aye
against the motion is carried all right
that brings us to the second item
uh streets alive and you will be in
receipt of a memo
from the chief executive
just before you start i probably
shouldn't declare not a financial
interest but i had worked on the streets
a lot
okay noted thank you um
so it's i guess the um
it results from a letter i wrote to the
chief executive of a
land transplant transport agency last
week
or on the 24th of may and a receipt of
her reply
on june the 3rd which i think was friday
this week
of this last week personally i was
disappointed
with the reply and i'd hoped that there
might have been
some some recognition of the challenges
that we've had
and the the scale of the the program
that have been rolled out in this town
for forward implementation of various
ones that the community decided
and council wanted to adopt going
forward but it appears that we're
just in in the mix with with everybody
else
and and given the challenges that we're
facing from
some of the community um then i think
that
we need to consider a way forward now
and there is a recommendation in the
in the memo from the chief executive
about
what that looks like so do you want to
make any comments steve
yeah thanks your worship and writing
this report which was only done
earlier today i've tried to
weigh up and i've had mr standering
as a co-collaborator and in the
timelines or the suggested um
program for graduate withdrawal but
trying to weigh up
the securing the benefits of the trial
against the strong
message being given by the public that
enough's enough
and also trying to
suggest a responsible way in which we
can gradually withdraw
get some early benefits but not throw
the
baby out of the bath water and that's
important in terms of collection of data
but we believe by monday we'll have the
crucial data
secured for the likes of broughton and
echo street
and then they can be opened up and then
that can be followed
pretty quickly by the other three
streets in west school
being kitchener anzac and pomona i have
suggested a working party
just because when peter stanner and i
talked
there was some thoughts about maybe
rather than just a wholesale removal of
some sites that there may be
advert advantages of making some
slight changes and i refer for example
to the equals
main street intersection and whether
there's a prohibition on a right turn
that's probably something that the
council's working with peter may well be
able to um
sort out on the ground um and so
and i think for i want to acknowledge
the stealing efforts of
of peter that so rather than him just
being forced to
make calls on the ground by himself he's
got some elected members there and some
electoral oomph from buying so he can he
can be confident of the decisions he's
making
because those decisions will need to be
made pretty quickly as because the
withdrawal program is only a matter
substantially over a couple of weeks
i think that's a very good way forward
and
i guess i i would apologize that this
has been dropped on councillors as an
urgent late item
i had anticipated that we would have had
the reply
from nicola rosie much earlier than we
than we did
which has necessitated the urgency today
i think it would be fitting for
councillors reid and macphail to be part
of that working party given the
intimate connection they've had with
the trial from the very beginnings
but i'm keen to hear from any other
counselors that might like to
put the hand up to be part of that i
know certainly i would be keen to be
part of that as well
counselor grant
um council read i'm very happy to be a
part of that you're on uh
your worship and i'd just like to make
comment on the fact that
that was nine working days to have an
answer back from nzta which is
absolutely appalling um and
i do think peter for the work that he's
put in so far
and yeah we'll see a good way forward
for the community i'm sure
um just the fact that we're even making
an effort
at this late stage even we've been held
up as i say by
nzta awaiting an answer and
i see in the last paragraph for the old
hammers out there just a tad
to make sure that um
we do the right thing but um i think we
need to take the community into
consideration at this point thank you
councilman it's just done backing up
what um councillor reed said
uh in regard to that obviously um
friends of waka katahi have um
slowed us down a bit and we've gone back
to them
and obviously we're now in the position
where we can bring it to the council as
a whole
and go forward on this i do note that
they haven't passed any comment in
regard to our
state highway 1 and chelten road
situation either
which was probably a primary drive as
well
so other than that i'm glad that the
community we managed to get through the
tussock creek
we had a very very favorable week last
week and i
toss a country and also the fact that
thank you councillor grant and also the
fact that
the hard work that peter's done and i
realize how hard it is
uh when we're we're trying to change
this and and uh regroup
without losing all the good stuff that
has come out of this and there is some
very good stuff that's come out with it
uh obviously along with a few issues or
a number of issues
okay counselor council grant
thank you worship um yeah i'm a hundred
percent
for opening or
these uh recommendations some of them
are
i don't know whether you want to take
the entire furniture out of
eric street but that's something your
committee can look at because some of
that worked very very well
a lot of this this was common sense
stuff right from the start we've always
said that
but we were the hand was forced
um it has been said that it was a
political decision but it wasn't it was
we were guided or goaded down it's only
a trial we've been told it was a trial
nz oh sorry wakka katah he said it's
only going to be a troll so that's fit
but you know as as counselors reading
and uh mcfaul
said you know we've had in your worship
it's just
the public showed their hand and
you know um those of us that are in the
public eye a lot more than other ones
are getting it all day every day and
it is time to uh to act i
am quite uh disheartened with that
letter from
um from the sea oh okay
it's just uh it's not on so now i'm 100
for uh for doing these um
obviously a few things got to stay
i had a very uh elderly lady i shouldn't
say she's very early
an elderly lady in the community she was
really really happy
with the courtesy crossings and she said
please leave the courtesy crossings
anywhere near
um the likes of windsor park or
paraza because they feel safe that they
can actually
go to there so there are things that
need to be discussed but there's
uh the common sense and also agree with
the
right turnout of eccles street and
possibly the right tournament ralton
street
uh because um you are turning across two
lanes of traffic
and um you know it's it is it's only a
matter of time
and it has been some really close calls
on that
so yeah that's my bit okay
any other comment from councillors
council dixon
um i just like to say that i
would like to support the recommendation
as well i think it's very good
that that you've taken up the challenge
and you've gone
to um to waka kahati
and but i'm just wondering where that
leaves us with them now
i mean does that put us off side
with them or we'll wait and see but
um i would hope not um they
they openly admitted in that or nicola
rosie openly admitted that we are
probably the most extensive of the
of the changes and activations of any
community
and i think that we've probably hung on
as long as we possibly could
some some towns have completely revolted
and said no this
is this is stopping so i think we we've
bent over backwards to work with them
and also to work with
with community where we can and and and
i do want to acknowledge peter like he's
had to put up with a
a really rough time over the last little
while when we talk about
councillor council staff getting abused
you know i'm i'm very aware that he's
had quite a bit of abuse that
is not deserved from from members of our
community
so so good on you peter for um getting
to this point and still smiling
um and and hopefully we can work through
the options that
that lie before us uh and there are some
really good things that have come out of
this and
you know look councillor grant talked
about the courtesy crossings i
personally struggle with courtesy
crossings but i've heard quite a number
of people say to me how much they like
them in particular places
um so i think together with
with staff counsellors on the working
party just need to take some time to
to work out what is the way forward but
i think the
the program that's been laid out in the
in the document from the chief executive
is a good one
starting not quite immediately but
almost immediately
uh certainly um next week and um
let's see where we end up from here
councillor phillips
thank you russia um i would like to be
part of the
group if that's possible just to keep a
bit of balance um i
i personally think that we should be
hanging there till the 28th
but that's my personal opinion um
and yeah there's some
people out there that have really upset
and it's the old nimby
situation it's not in my backyard
scenario and um i think there's been
some lessons learned
but i think that we we could go forward
with some really good recommendations to
the community and i think they'll
probably take it on board
okay um so a council comfortable that we
have councilman fail councillor reed
council grant and council phillips and
myself on a working party with
with staff to go forward yeah i'm very
happy and i'll move in that direction
thank you thank you
okay uh i think that covers so you're
moving
um both recommendations yep thank you
did i put that motion no i'll put the
emotion all those in favor please say i
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors
and thank you for your forbearance uh
with this particular project i know that
certainly in my time in council this is
probably one of the most high profile
ones that councillors have had to deal
with
and and i do acknowledge that um some
councillors are more accessible than
others and it can be quite tiring at
times
it's a trial by name and a trial by
nature um the last
couple of months that we've been went
through this but but i think long term
it's opened our eyes to what is possible
and
and it will bring benefit for this
community i
have no doubt okay so i think we're
at the end of our uh open session of the
of the council agenda so i would move
that we go into
public excluded and
if i can find the wording i will read
that right now
to discuss the subject of
a number of matters um the general
subject of each matter is confirmation
of minutes
minutes of the 20 of 11 may meeting
of council 19 may meeting of council
other business minutes i've ordered and
risk hakanu runanga charter of
understanding
awarding the contract for wigan street
wastewater and
muruhiku nursery project somebody liked
to
second that motion please thank you
council reed
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion
is carried thank you councillors so
we'll just wait for about two six